for the latest mini election trick I'm
off across London to see Magic nawaz the
Liberal Democratic candidate in
Hampstead in Kilburn as the chairman of
counter extremism organization Julia he
is a controversial figure but is that
exactly what the Liberal Democrats need
in this seat a three-way marginal had
betrayed an election by planet water in
the Ramayana is what was going to be a
two-way margin all this time so what I
hope is that my particular kinda see my
presence in this constituencies is bring
something different to the campaign it
brings a different edge to it I'm not a
career politician I only joined the
Liberal Democrats a six months before
the two thousand 2010 and actually it's
my first time standing and my whole
campaign has a huge backstory to it I'm
somebody who was as a youth as a
sixteen-year-old actually very very
disillusioned with democracy in the
democratic process I grew up during the
Bosnia genocide I grew up a year before
the murder of Steven lon certain time
that I was facing seriously violent
racist attacks in Essex and as a result
of that disillusionment I became a what
I classifies a revolutionary islamist i
joined an Islamist organization that's
still legal but nevertheless extreme and
I spent all of my youth as an activist
when they recruiter for for this group
and that led me eventually um to Egypt
where I was a held as a political
prisoner and adopted by Amnesty
International as a prisoner of
conscience but my own views began
changing um you know from 24 onwards
after my stint as a political prisoner
and I began reconsidering some of the
anger that I had internalized growing up
and that led me eventually to begin a
counter extremism organization called
Quilliam and start campaigning for
smaller liberal Human Rights values and
eventually that led me to stand for
positive quilliam obviously has made the
headlines quite a lot with fairy stance
on things i think when Tommy memo the
BBC and documentary you featured in
there and also the whole debate over the
jesus and mo cartoons as well has that
helped toward attracted your campaign at
all here I think it's helped I think
people are able to you know when we talk
about brand
recognition we talked about you know
people associating a candidate with
things often the complaint is rewarded
the Liberal Democrats stand for and I
think the messaging from over the last
eight to nine months h qs messaging the
parties messaging has been a lot clearer
but you know there was that question
where's in my case because of the two
examples you've just mentioned and many
others but particularly because of these
two everyone kind of knows if they know
who I am they know what I stand you know
and thatthat's that's something where
you know people are often in this day
and age where we are faced with so much
confusion about politics about cohesion
and communities people are looking for
somebody who's a conviction politician
and and you know people often say oh we
want someone who will stand up for the
area and it has been reported as whether
liberal Democrat HQ have taken resources
away from this seat because of the whole
worry about that is that true and heavy
how's that impact being felt well I
think I I don't think that taking
resources away from marginal seats which
happened across the country was anything
to do with that incident you mentioned I
think it's more so that after the last
May's local election results they've had
to really concentrate look the Liberal
Democrats on a wealthy party um labor
have the unions and the Tories have big
business the Liberal Democrats struggle
through donations to make ends meet and
that's just the nature of this party
that suits me in that sense as well cuz
I've always like to kind of you know
side with the underdog that's it for
this mini election adventure join me
again soon to find out how the election
is being fought in a different part of
the country find out more at mini
election co uk